- So I'm Jessica Seddon.
I am a senior fellow at
the Yale Jackson School
of Global Affairs, and I am
very happy to have been invited
to chair the last panel of the day,
which is always kind of a daunting thing
on a day that also starts at 8:30
and involves as many
papers and difficult topics
and thoughts and possibilities
as these sessions have.
I'm also the Jessica who
was invoked in the beginning
of the session as saying
that the climate emergency is here now.
Now I'm not gonna revise that,
I'm just gonna add a little addendum.
I think what's happening when
you start to look at some
of the growing pile of scientific evidence
is that we have an unfolding,
likely an accelerating set
of environmental changes
that include but go way
beyond temperature, rainfall,
and sea level rise.
These are changes that we have
an increasingly well grounded,
bounded understanding of.
We have an understanding of
some of the non-linearities
and also a great sense of
what we don't understand about
how those are going to affect
the infrastructure services.
economic setup that we have.
Ecuador right now is
having rolling blackouts.
It's a highly hydro
electric dependent economy,
and El Nino has not been so
great for hydro electricity.
That's a little bit out of bounds
from what's happened historically.
These are the kinds of things that we can,
from the science side, anticipate.
At the same time, on the human side,
it's pretty clear that we are
a species that is not passive,
that is entirely capable of responding
to very significant changes,
both local, regional, and global.
Sometimes we're self-interested,
often we're banal,
we suffer from moral hazard.
And I think some of the papers
have highlighted frictions
that are deeply social in how
we adapt to these changes.
But we know these things, these
two sides, these two streams
of knowledge from very large
intellectual enterprises,
both on the climate science
and climate impacts modeling,
on the one side and
then also from economics
and more broadly social
science understanding
of micro foundations.
I think we have an enormous amount
of knowledge about the first principles,
the dynamics of environmental
change on the one side,
the dynamics of human
responses on the other.
Our challenge going ahead is
how do we put these two streams
together more effectively?
How do we better combine
this understanding
of the micro to maybe meso foundations
to build an understanding
and the sense of ability to
make some of the trade-offs
that we need to make now,
use of scarce resources now versus later,
this versus that, here versus there.
What are some of the narratives,
the balance, urgency,
but also recognize agency and adaptation
and anticipating costs.
Most importantly, and for me,
what are some of the ways
that a combined stream
of understanding the climate dynamics
very, very well at high resolution
and the human social dynamics
at higher resolution,
what does that say?
What does that tell us
about interventions,
policy instruments,
investments in information,
investments in credible information?
The the kinds of
institutions we might need
to create social tipping points to respond
to the environmental and
climate tipping points
that are increasingly,
unfortunately, looking
within, looking more probable.
I think with that,
that enterprise is both
an intellectual one.
It's a research agenda,
but it's also in some
ways an institutional one
in how we organize
interdisciplinary conversations,
interdisciplinary research agendas
and spaces for framing the questions,
setting agendas, talking
about how we represent humans
and climate models and
climate and human models.
And for that we have the next hour
to figure all that stuff out.
But look, luckily we
have an excellent panel.
I'll introduce them in a second
and ask them to come up
for some opening remarks.
But I just wanted to also
say one other thing just
to set expectations about this,
is this is also a bit of a tortured panel.
We have an hour and 10 minutes
left, hour and 15 minutes.
And what I've asked the
panelists to do in kind
of design thinking mode
is give opening remarks
on what they, in their work experience,
what they in their research
and their practice as policy makers
and as people who have been
engaging in interdisciplinary
conversations,
what they see as gaps in
combining the human side
and the climate side.
And then we'll have a discussion
of some of those gaps.
Then we'll come back for five
relatively longer remarks
from each of the panelists
on what can we do to
resolve some of these gaps.
Hopefully looking at the problem first,
then responding with solutions
will lead us to some ideas
that wouldn't have occurred
to the four panelists
just coming in fresh.
So we're hoping to have
that kind of discussion.
And at the end, leave some time for Q & A.
So I wanna introduce the panel first
and I'll call them up one by one,
but I'm gonna introduce
everybody now so you can see
where people or anticipate maybe
where people are coming from.
Everybody's bios are
on the conference program.
But our first speaker will be Tony Smith,
who is a professor of economics
and chair of the department at Yale.
His research is mostly
looking at global economy
climate models with high
geographic resolution
or that's his most recent focus.
So I'm anticipating that he'll come
with perspectives from building those.
Our second speaker will
be Regina Rodriguez,
who is a Professor of
Physical Oceanography
and climate at the
University of Santa Katerina,
Federal University of
Santa Katerina in Brazil.
She co-chairs the World
Climate Research Program,
Atlantic Region Panel
and Marine Heat Waves Research Focus.
She's also a co-principal
investigator of my climate risk,
which she'll tell you a bit more about.
Third speaker is Piers Forster,
who's professor of climate
physics and the founding director
of the Priestly International Center
for Climate at University of Leeds.
He's also the interim chair
for the UK Climate Change Committee.
He's known for his work
on radiative forcing,
climate sensitivity and has been a lead
or contributing lead author
for the fourth, fifth,
and sixth IPCC reports,
as well as the 2018 special
warming report on special,
special report on global
warming of 1.5 degrees Celsius.
So, and our fourth
speaker, Tejal Kanitkar,
who gets the prize for being
up the latest of all of us
'cause it's 3:30 AM where she is now,
will be coming in by Zoom,
is an associate professor
at the National Institute
Advanced Studies in Bangalore,
India, also an IPCC author.
And her work has been looking
at equity within the general
enterprise of climate modeling.
So I think we've got a great panel
coming from different perspectives.
Hopefully between all of us we
can describe some of the gaps
and solve some of them.
With further ado, I'll
turn it over to Tony
for five minute opening remarks.
Thanks.
(people clapping)
- Alright, thanks a lot
for including me in this
in this workshop today
and this conference.
It's been a fascinating,
a long but fascinating
and also stimulating day.
I've quite enjoyed it.
So I have a,
I couldn't,
I didn't wanna risk not having slides.
So I have one slide with
words and two pictures,
but are those gonna be,
can I just go ahead?
- [Speaker] The clicker should work.
- Okay, got it.
- [Speaker] It should all be lined up.
- Yeah.
- And now I'll have the same problem
everyone else is having.
- Okay.
- [Speaker] Oh no, you're going backwards.
- Sorry, yeah.
There we go, there I am.
Alright, so this is my
one slide with words.
So what I've been working on,
I'm a macro economist by training
and have worked on
heterogeneous agent models
of the macroeconomy of
heterogeneity across households
and since parlayed that methodological,
those methodological skills into building
or attempting to build high resolution
integrated assessment models.
So the idea here is to build
computational laboratories
for evaluating the effects
of climate change in a high degree
of resolution geographically.
And in particular, what I've
been working on most recently
is to merge earth system models
with dynamic general
equilibrium economic models
to incorporate in particular weather
and extreme events as well as climate.
So it's called two-Way
coupling the literature.
I think I'm partly on this panel too,
because I am working with
two climate scientists
on this coupling that we're working on.
Trudy Sarelmo used to be here at Yale
and that's where I met her.
And now she's in Norway and
it turns out she's a co-author
with Pierce Forster on part
of the IPCC report I just learned today.
And then one of her students.
So we're working together trying
to integrate these two models
and this next point is a
little bit a point more
for climate scientists, but
there's a more economist here
and fewer climate scientists maybe.
But we're trying to build
a fully articulated,
what we call a structural model
that spells out the behavior
of the climate system and how
it interacts with the economy
and how agents behave
and how they respond to various policies
that might be designed to
a address climate change.
So we can look at
quantitatively the effects
of counterfactual policies
and ask questions like, how do
resources move across space?
How that spatial adaptation
seems critical here,
who gains and who loses?
And once you have a model like this,
you can then ask questions about
doing a detailed quantitative analysis
of international climate agreements
or international sharing of climate risk.
So I'll just show my one picture.
This is just an example.
This actually looks a lot like
pictures that we've seen today,
although it's coming
from a very different set
of methodologies and tools.
Without going into details,
this is showing a counterfactual
experiment in a model
calibrates of the global
economy showing who gains
and who lose loses from
a uniform tax on carbon.
These are percentages
of consumption per year.
So basically places that are already hot
are losing, so sorry,
places that are already hot
like a carbon tax,
they wanna slow down warming
and they're gaining, so that's
just Sub-Saharan Africa.
That's Saharan Africa.
Russia is actually
losing from a carbon tax
because they're cold and
we like to warm a bit.
So we've actually seen this picture
several times today, I think.
Another thing we can do is
look at inequality, say,
so we have this, the
model's actually broken
into 19,000 little regions.
So each,
I'm experiencing what other
people have experienced.
So each agent is a little, is a region,
sorry, each agent is a little region.
So 19,000 of these interact
them through markets,
they make consumption saving
decisions, enter decisions,
they respond to tax policy.
They interact through capital markets
and they interact through
the global climate system.
Alright, so once we have
this model, then I can ask,
how will inequality change over time?
So this is showing across,
this is GDP per capita by country,
not region, aggregated countries.
You can see the 90/10
percentiles in measure of inequality.
It starts at 30,
and according to my model,
increases to around 46.
That's the top line.
The second line shows what
happens in an optimal tax.
And this model actually doesn't
change things very much,
but the point is that you
you can run this
counterfactual experiment.
Alright, so what I would say
we need, so getting to my last,
that's sort of where I'm coming in
and what I'm doing,
the challenges that I face or face
is working across disciplines.
It's just getting that conversation going,
understanding how an
earth system model runs
and then teaching the
climate scientists how my
economic model runs and why I need
to think about forward
looking behavior, say.
And I think the more we
can get people together,
like in rooms like this
and get interaction going,
the more we can build more
plausible and interesting models.
So I would say we need micro
and macro economists, we
need climate scientists,
we need ecologists, geographers,
and a number of the papers today,
like Valerie's paper
and then the paper on Jakarta
that Alan just gave.
Papers this morning.
All those papers can maybe inform
the macro model that I'm building.
And then next, what I think
we really need in this space
is powerful computing resources
and technical expertise
on numerical analysis
and coding to solve these models.
Alright, so all I think I'm done.
I'll stop there.
All right, it's my five minutes.
(people clapping)
- Okay, we have in the order...
Sorry, I have to come to the mic,
In the order dictated by
the slides deity we have,
well we have Regina is our next speaker,
also, just as a background
for these opening remarks,
the ask was where are you coming,
where do you come from in terms
of your past research and what is the,
what are the types of
problems that you see?
So hopefully we'll get some commonalities
and some convergences over to you.
- Hi, thank you.
I would like to thank you
Jessica for inviting me.
And so I'm, as she said, I'm a
climate scientist from Brazil
and I work particularly
with climate variability
and extremes in South America.
Our region has been exposed
to many hazards, lately, as you can see.
As you can know.
And I realized that most
of the climate information
generated by scientists
wasn't reaching the people
the most need, society.
This is a perspective from
obviously climate scientists
and climate information
mainly in the global south.
And in order to reduce the vulnerability,
increase the resilience.
So Jessica ask us to say
what we think that is the big gaps.
And in our case, for the
case there has been a call
for usable or actionable
climate information.
Yet despite this awareness
and global effort, it's widely accepted
that there is a significant
gap between the production
and the use of climate information.
And I argue that the gap
results in part from US climate
sciences folks on better data
and models rather than
better decision making.
So it's going really fast.
Okay, well we generally use a top down
as a climate scientist approach
that adopts a disciplinary
based measures of scientific quality.
The problem is that even if
user informed such a top down
approach is inevitably drive
by US climate scientists themselves.
And that has violated the core
principle of co-production
of this climate information.
Sorry.
So our traditional,
That's where I wanted to be.
So our traditional ways
of producing aggregate
climate information can leave
climate scientists empty
handed for many regions
of the word, particularly
in the global south.
For example, this figure
from the last IPCC reports,
aggregated all the information from data
and models described in literature
to identify if there has
been changes in precipitation
leading to agriculture
or ecological drought.
But they did this exercise for the aspects
and you can see the regions
for which there is limited data
or literature on past
change are showing gray
with low agreement on the
type of change showing hatch.
And all with low confidence
in the human contribution
to those change due
to limited evidence is showing open.
And we can see that vast areas
of the global map are
these too gray hatched all
with open estate.
This is due to the limited
long-term data records
or poor representation of
climate models of the relevant
physical processes behind extreme events
and ambiguous model prediction
of the forced response
to climate change for those regions,
mainly in the global south, again.
Yet there can be a wealth
of local climate knowledge if you watch,
look to the chapter 10
and that is ignored when we try
to do this aggregation.
So my last thing that I
wanna say that is then,
climate change science as
its current practice tends
to frame the scientific questions
as singular definitive ones.
It does this by focus on
projections from climate models
and emphasize where there is consensus
among them acknowledging uncertainty,
but not ex actually exploring it.
The focus of a single definitive
problem is also expressed
in a still common practice across most
published climate change science
to interpret statistical
significance in a dichotomous
true false manner
and avoid the articulation
of a multiple possible
hypothesis which you would
allow a plural conditional
framing of uncertainty.
(people clapping)
- Okay, well it is been a
very interesting day today.
So I'll tell you where I come from.
So I am a
climate scientist
and I spent a long time just trying
to make the best possible projections
of the average
surface temperature.
And if you look at the IPC report,
IPCC report from last time,
we were able to make a significant change
from what we've done before.
We have this
simple
kind of physical climate vital emulator
that we are able to kind calibrate
with the more sophisticated ones.
And in particular for the IPCC report,
we were also able to calibrate
it to the observation
and be able to calibrate it with good
physical understanding
from the different chapters
of the IPCC report.
And we were able to put the
lines of evidence together
to be able to
constrain our surface temperature
projection for the first time.
And by doing this, we were able
to exclude some possible
very high surface temperature projections.
So for your economists doing all your
kind of fiscal analysis,
that should be a fantastic
thing to be able to include.
And it is really encouraging that this
model has been taken up by your community.
I've heard the Bill Nord
house is now included in his
tastes model.
He's a fantastic economist,
but he's not a good climate modeler
and the actual kind climate
modeling component was a bit,
well I'm not gonna say anything.
I mean he's a great guy.
But anyway, so he had replaced
it by the one that we had,
which is great
and this is the one that would also,
so the United States government
use to calculate their
social cost of carbon with.
So that's fantastic.
And I absolutely appreciate the citations,
but I would appreciate far more than that,
the conversations and
interesting that was,
that was done without talking to us.
And it's only people like us that
we really comprehend, understand,
or that assumptions
that actually go into the calculations.
And I think far more than just
the conversations as well,
I'd appreciate the change as well that,
of course, the projection
depend on the thing
that you guys know, like the
GDP and the population changes
and all the other things.
And it would be good to be able
to work out the way they
interact by the conversations.
And as Jessica said
at the end of a introduction,
I have recently become
a politician and it's
very interesting that
you can give governments the very best
evidence package very well,
but they don't necessarily
do anything with that.
And we haven't got a lot of time
But I think we can act
together as a community.
We sort of can do things.
So the inflation reduction
act was a good opportunity,
for example, where there
are these instances
and I do now know in my new position
that I suddenly get a
telephone call from number 10
and they say, Pete, can you
think there's something to do?
So there are the opportunity
and I think if we as a
community have that sense
of urgency to affect change,
I think we can try and do
things a bit differently.
(people clapping)
- So while we're switching the screen over
to our fourth panelist, Tejal Kanitkar,
who's joining us from Bangalore,
I just wanted to highlight one thing
that Pierce mentioned
which is we're the ones
who know the assumptions underneath this.
And I think that may be
one of the focal points
for the kinds of conversations
and the conversation
space that we can have.
Let me know when you're up
there Tejal for opening remarks.
- Thank you Jessica.
And it's been great listening
to all the interventions
throughout the day.
Well, it's been throughout
the night for me,
but since there's very little time,
let me jump right into it.
I'm going to speak about the macro models,
especially the integrated
assessment model.
So some of the first
of which in fact came from
the Department of Economics at Yale.
Of course, I am very
grateful to peers for being
sufficiently provocative so that I sound,
I may sound less so.
The IAMs have become the
dominant modeling tool
for projecting social economic
and related energy use
trends into the future.
The sixth assessment report
of the IPCC depends quite
heavily on these IAMs.
While there are a range of
discussions in the IPCC reports
about a lot of other things,
the summary for in the global
model scenarios from the IAMs
disproportionately dominate
the summary for policy makers,
which are then further even
more disproportionately picked
up by the media and
then even more distilled
and used without the accompanying context
very often in COP decisions, right?
So both COP 26 and COP 27,
for example, quote the number
of 43% reductions in GE emissions,
which corresponds to the median
of all global scenarios
assessed by the IPCC
for the 1.5 degree cells here target.
So it's become a prescription for policy
and so it becomes
important to analyze this.
My work focuses on questions of equity
and justice in modeling
burden sharing models
as well as other kinds of models.
So I'm not going to go into the details
of what the IAMs are.
I'm speaking to an audience
that is probably more aware
of what these do than I am.
But what we have
essentially is a combination
of macroeconomic models that are based on
neoclassical frameworks,
energy models that focus on minimization
of costs of abatement,
vegetation models with that
system feedbacks coupled
with scenario frameworks that
are essentially socioeconomic
storylines for the future.
So you have,
will there be sustainable development,
will there be fossil fuel dependence?
Will there be cooperation
or regional rivalry?
These are the kinds of storylines
that are projected into the future.
But I think one of the first issues
is that the world in
these models is divided
by geographical regions.
And this is what we saw
throughout the day as well when
modeling results were presented.
Which itself is a problem I think
because Gina spoke a little
bit about the problem of risks
and how they're assessed
when this happens.
But such a distribution doesn't
tell us about differentiated
levels of development,
production, consumption, etcetera.
When there is an economic differentiation
is only for the OECD.
So it's only the OECD that are economies.
The rest of us are
essentially just geographies.
And so that is one issue.
The second is of course, that
irrespective of storylines
that you construct,
the macroeconomic models that essentially
pursue PTO optimality
and most of the macroeconomic models
that follow the structure
and the frameworks that are used,
freeze income inequalities
at current levels,
not allowing any more conversions than is
considered reasonable
based on historical trends.
So you have inequalities in,
these are for results
of the IPCC scenarios
that we have assessed.
About 556 scenarios corresponding
to the 1.5 and two degrees
Celsius temperature targets.
So you have any inequalities
that persist across regions even by 2050.
These GDP and consumption figures
are, of course, linked quite
significantly with energy.
And so you have energy poverty
and energy inequalities that
persist also throughout.
And this is tied to how energy
demand and supply are modeled
and coupled with the macroeconomic models.
The objective is to minimize
the cost of mitigation.
So the solution is to
find optimality in terms
that are both spatially
and temporarily cheaper.
So if it is cheaper to reduce emissions
to agricultural and forestry
in the developing countries
as compared to say the
reduction of oil, gas,
and coal use in developed countries,
that will be the solution.
And so you have extreme
levels of energy equality,
persisting across model
scenarios even in the future.
And the models therefore then
end up projecting much higher
levels of mitigation burdens,
both in the short and the long
term on developing countries.
On an average, for example,
Sub-Saharan Africa is expected
to reduce emissions by 80% in this decade
across the scenarios.
Whereas the reductions
are about 50% for Europe
and North America,
in line with the NDCs of
these countries, right?
The models also project large amounts
of carbon dioxide removal across models.
Most of this is coming from the
global south through energy,
the diversion of land from food crops
to energy crops increasing
the risk of hunger
across the regions.
And so therefore the current
trend of decreasing hunger,
decreasing risk of hunger
is in fact reversed in some
of the more extreme
scenarios that are assessed
by the IPCC in the future.
So the questions of equity questions,
of dealing with questions
of vulnerability and risk,
which are unequally distributed today
and remain unequally
distributed even in the future,
are not addressed with the
current modeling framework.
The global south is denied
the means to build resilience
that we've been speaking
about throughout the day
and this is a major gap, but
there are ways to address this
and maybe we come back to this state.
So I'll stop here, thank you.
(people clapping)
- I think the opening
remarks have really raised
two classes of problems.
One is the, in some ways you could call it
the internal discussion
between groups of experts.
So to what extent are the findings
and the assumptions, and
not just the headline,
but also the guts of the different models
about how humans behave,
what are the embedded pieces in the story?
What are the assumptions
that are made in order
to deliver an estimate
of surface temperature?
What are the obstacles
to having a conversation
about those assumptions
and whether or not those are reasonable
and whether the inferences about, say,
human responses to the average
surface temperature are really capturing
human responses to the
larger set of things
that are embedded in the model.
So one is the conversation
between experts.
The other is the fact
that these conversations
and these models and these representations
also shape social conversations
at multiple levels.
So there's the issue
that Tejal referred to
and I think what Pierce referred to is,
and with the use of the models
in informing kind of macro decisions
and the issue that Regina pointed out,
which is in some ways the
use of risk information
and informing and in dialogue
at the community level.
Both of these are important.
Both of these information
flows are important
because obviously the link
between what you understand
of environmental change
shapes your response,
shapes the environmental
change and for it.
So you can't really see
these as two isolated issues.
I think if would've, just for
the purpose of discussion,
if we could tackle these
two a little bit distinctly.
'cause otherwise we end up with a big sort
of ball of things.
I guess the first question is, Tony,
you mentioned having the conversation
and the importance of
having the conversations,
but in each of your professional lives,
have you found easy ways
to have those conversations?
Have you been professionally rewarded
for having those conversations
and are there ways to make it easier
and more rewarding to do that?
If you haven't found that already.
What would it take to make
it a more normal part?
And we can just, we can start
with you Tony, and work through the panel.
- Okay.
I think I use that same
phrase in my slides,
that we wanna reward
this kind of interaction.
I think in general it's quite difficult
to reward that interaction.
We're kind of siloed in
departments with certain standards
for tenure and especially
for younger people,
it might be a little bit
risky to try to go work
with some climate scientists
on our risky project about
building a big climate model
that incorporates earth system richness.
So I don't have a particular
answer for how to address that.
I think somehow that, we need to reward
people doing this ind of work
and very often, even within economics,
you'd be across two
subfields of economics.
Sometimes it can be difficult
because you're talking
to two different audiences sometimes.
So I don't have a
particular answer to that.
Somehow we need to
recognize in departments
or in universities that this kind
of work across disciplines
is super important.
And it may not satisfy
everyone in all the camps,
but it's a new product
that no one's ever seen
before and it offers something special.
So it's a question of what
journals you publish in
and there's a whole set of issues there.
And in terms of getting
conversation started,
I think that's hard too because
we just don't see each other.
I think it was Ken Gillingham
who was here earlier
to school the environment,
organized a conference on
getting together macro
economists and economists
and climate scientists up
in the school environment
a few years ago where I started talking
to climate scientists
and realizing that I was in
over my head a little bit
on my own.
So I needed to like learn from them that,
that's how I met Trudy.
And then one thing led to another,
but it takes a while to
learn how to be comfortable
with people and how to trust
people and the cooperation.
So we had to nurture that
relationship for a while,
but now it's up and running.
- So just one question.
I mean, other than that do you,
when you look around at other universities
or other academic spaces,
do you see an example
of something small that
could be scaled up?
Are there lighthouses
that we could work from?
- Offhand, I don't really
so much to be honest.
You're looking for an example
of maybe two very different disciplines,
someone's working across
them and being successful.
I'm sure there are, but yeah,
I can't think of any offhand.
I know within economics, I think a bit
of an issue actually, to be honest.
- Well, we can take that as a challenge
for Yale Planetary Solutions.
We can make that as a challenge
- I'm not trying to be, I mean
maybe I'm too pessimistic.
Others could disagree with me,
but that's kind of my take on it.
- Thank you.
And Regina, I think coming from the,
coming from a different discipline,
what has been your experience
with building projects
like my climate risk
or some of these more interactive speaking
with decision makers kinds of projects?
And I'll pass you this mic.
- So I think you respond
to your previous question a little bit.
For our US climate scientists,
the problem is that we are rewarded
by papers and is a
pontification and not policies.
I think if we could be,
as a scientist also be reward when we,
in our career for tenure
and we focus too much
in the number of papers
that we publish and
not to actually results
of the science that could
be used for policy purpose
and is a challenge to publish papers
in multidisciplinary papers,
journals, that actually accept
when you're transversal.
This is also a challenge.
And for us, the point I wanna make
is that we generally, in our style,
we come up with ideas
or things that we think
that needs to be studied
and understand and we generated
this climate information
and then when you go to the communities,
it's not exactly what they need.
And so now in the World
Club research program,
we have this kind of a
new activity that we go
to the communities and
we needed to talk to them
and then created the
information, not try to adjust
that information that we already
have in a form that we are
have and then try to kind of push it down.
So then it's a kind of
a bottom up approach
and that's what we are trying to do
and have this conversation
with the communities from the beginning
and make them to be able to
then use that information
and even create the
information that they need
and be self-sustained
and to make, let's see.
- But I think I just
wanna highlight one thing
that Regina pointed out in the supply
and demand of different
scales of integrated models
or different scales of climate,
even just climate impact and risk models.
In some ways the whole enterprise
of integrated assessment
models came out of an expressed
demand for an ability to make
a certain kind of decision.
And I think there is a broader
question when we're thinking
of what is the agenda to
build humans and climate,
climate and humans?
We need to acknowledge a broader set
of demanders and needs
that may not be as visible
as macroeconomic national
or state policymaking.
And that's a whole other challenge.
And so just to flag that this research
and institutional agenda
for combining the two
has multiple sub areas depending on needs
that can be really quite different.
Not to complicate things.
Back to you Pierce on,
have you been rewarded for
having the conversation?
- Well, I absolutely
have done, I probably,
the best example is the IPCC report on
kind of one and a half degrees.
I mean this, the IPCC
terribly institutionalized
and kind of siloed,
but just for this report on one
and a half degrees, everything changed.
When we were set a tight timeline
and we had to get all
the disciplines together
from the engineers with
the kinda solutions
to the energy experts, to
the climate scientists,
to the economic expert, to the kind of,
to the kind of political experts.
We had to get them all together
and we had to come up
with a kind of report
and it was incredibly successful,
it sort of started
the every country
trying to get these net zero targets.
And that kind of began my job in projects,
but it also inspired me to
set up an interdisciplinary
research
as well where we try
and bring different disciplines together.
And what I find from doing that is,
it doesn't work for the old professors,
but it certainly works for
the younger generation.
They don't particularly,
particularly care if
their climate scientist
or an economist.
They sort of just want to change the world
and they sort of want to
want to kind of cherry pick
and be taught the expertise
to change the world.
And I sort of think time de
celebrating for all of us too.
Like we have artificial
intelligence on the kind of horizon
and that could really
change our kind disciplines.
So I just think to be on
the kind of cutting edge,
we sort of ought to do that.
Cool things are fun.
- There's the ought to, I
think the question is how to,
how to set up some of the
incentives to do it more often.
I mean, I think who you're
seeing on this panel here are all
people who have taken
the trouble to do this.
And I just wanna sort of
summarize where we are now
before turning it over to Tejal,
which is in some ways we have okay,
it's hard, there are frictions,
just like there are with adaptation,
but in some ways if we can,
there's a willingness, there's a goodwill,
there's potentially younger scientists
who wanna change the world,
but then there's also
where there's a pull, there's a response
and that research then generates
or potentially could
start a positive cycle.
So that leads us, I think
into a second set of questions
that will come to and how
do we articulate that pull
and respond to it effectively knowing
that there are frictions
for doing so in the way that
sciences are structured.
I wanna turn it back to you
Tejal, for just your thoughts on
rewards and how to increase
them for the kind of work
that excavates the assumptions
that you've been looking at
and yeah, your thoughts on
what might make it easier
to reduce the frictions.
- Yeah, I think, I mean
I agree with the peers
to the extent that
there is definitely a difference
in how younger people.
Now my students for example, I have a mix
of social scientists and
engineers as students
and they work together and collaborate
and produce work together
because the environment
in which we do science
has changed to a certain extent.
And the problem of climate change,
I think everybody is recognized doesn't,
respect disciplinary boundaries.
You need to speak across disciplines.
But I think another issue is that
while IPCC is not just siloed
in terms of disciplines,
but also in terms of
where authors come from.
I mean especially if you look at the IAMs
and the scenario modeling, it's
largely based in the global
north and that's a,
if you talk about global climate policy,
that's a huge gap because you have 82%
of the global population that's very,
very invested in climate
policy making and negotiations,
but plays very little role in introducing
and assessing the science,
be it the natural science,
or the physical science
or the social science that
goes into the IPCC reports.
And that perhaps needs to change also
as conversations are changing
with the newer generations
maybe doing things differently.
- So just one, I mean I think
that that raises a really,
that is a good segue
into a really important
second set of questions.
Sorry, I'm human so I can't speak to you
and have Tejal's face behind me,
which is why I have
this awkward pose here.
But I think that segues into
the second set of questions,
which is really how do we create
and articulate not only a demand
for the kind of integrated
research to inform questions
that are very present here and now,
but also some degree of discernment
and willingness for not everybody,
but at least somebody
to look into the assumptions
in ever more complicated models,
either climate or human or both.
And to highlight the problematic ones
because I think that
articulation of demand
as well as building of discernment
are two critical features of creating
an environment that might be sufficient
to push us over the frictions,
to generating a useful set of knowledge.
Tejal do you have any ideas on that?
What might just increase the discernment
and draw more attention
to these assumptions,
these and other assumptions?
- I don't know, that's
a bit of a difficult
question in the sense that a lot of,
it depends on what assumptions
we are talking about.
For example, in the climate science,
domain,
you deal with a lot of known unknowns
and a lot of unknown unknowns.
And as our understanding
of the natural world expands,
our computational capacities increase.
We perhaps are able to answer questions
and look at assumptions more closely.
But in the social sciences
and especially when you couple these
with the natural sciences as happens
in the modeling domain,
a lot of the frictions
are ideological perhaps
and also based on perspectives in terms
of where we come from
and the kind of questions
that we're interested in.
Modeling in the global north
interested in answering
questions of equity
or is it something that only
researchers in the
global south will raise?
And if the raise, will there be a,
will there be capacity to respond
to that demand in the global south?
So will we be able to
build models for example,
that don't trade off equity
against efficiency, right?
That don't start with the objective
function of minimizing cost,
but perhaps start with
the objective function
of maximizing resilience.
So do we have the capacity to respond
to that demand even though
there is a political demand
to address those kinds of questions?
So that I think still remains open.
So it's not something
that you can answer perhaps
in a uniform fashion
across domains in my opinion.
- So I wanna ask you next
Regina for your thoughts.
I mean you showed a nice graph
that's clearly in the public domain
and it's in the IPCC report of where,
what level of certainty
we have about relevant
climatic conditions in
different areas of the world
and made the point that underneath
some of the more general
predictions and statements,
there is a huge geographic variation
in the origins of that information.
That's something that's out there,
but it's not widely known or recognized.
Do you see a space
or a way to create more discernment
and demand for evening that out?
- Yes, so what we are trying to develop
in the world climb research
program now is hubs,
local hubs that they,
and we can help them to develop
the information that is available.
I'll give an example 'cause
otherwise, so the MET office
of Brazil doesn't do a good job
of delivering a seasonal prediction,
which is really important
for agriculture, energy.
Brazil is hydroelectric 65%.
So that's really important
for energy purpose too.
And I live in a southern Brazil
and certainly the
predictions from the METOFs
for the whole Brazil and
southern Brazil doesn't work.
The global predictions from you know,
other places also doesn't work.
You need a lot of investment
in capacity building
and money to run these models,
which is not available.
So what we do is we get
the local state government,
a small group of meteorologists
and we help them develop simple tools
that they can get this information from,
say emergency response.
My state has a lot of extreme events
and then we are doing this,
we getting these hubs around the world,
particularly in the global cell
and help them with really simple tools
that doesn't require too much money.
We have this information
already enough information
available to make them more
resilient and then they learn
and they can be self-sufficient
to start to kind
of producing that climate
information that they need
for say whatever, emergency responsible
extreme events or I dunno,
energy, etcetera,
policies.
- Just gonna steal this
back for one second.
So I wanna leave time
for, I'm gonna come back,
I wanna leave time for
questions from the room
and from Zoom, but just
to quickly summarize
and take a poll of the panelists
on whether we're on the right track
in terms of an agenda for
being able to do this better.
If there are two buckets,
one is something to do
with generating greater
and more influential pull
for effective integration,
recognizing that that pull must be,
or that agenda setting must
be more equitable than it has
been in the past and may
ask different questions,
may pose different challenges
for integrated models.
So some intervention on the pull side,
hoping that the pull
helps grow
efforts to overcome frictions,
inspires early career researchers
and perhaps highlights some of the,
we don't have a good answer yet on
what would remove the frictions
for bringing the two groups together,
but there's a pull side that is necessary
for unlocking the friction side
that we don't have a good bet for.
Is that a reasonable two buckets
or is there a third class
of to-do agenda
that I'm missing?
- I do think that's fine, Jessica,
- Anybody have anything to add?
Tejal?
Tony, you looked like
you were about to add.
- I mean, I guess I'm not sure,
tell me what you mean by a pull side.
You mean a demand for better
integrated assessment models
that can address say distributional
issues around the world
or inequality some amount?
So you're looking for some mechanism
that would lead more people to feel like
that's a good endeavor to
engage in their research.
Is that what you're asking?
- Yeah, I mean a pull or a voice, an ask.
- Yeah,
I should interpret that
as really principally coming from the kind
of demand that there is such a demand
by society kind of can kind of really
to give them actionable answers that work
for different countries
and that is the big kind of pool
as far as I'm concerned.
And I mean, and I think
that pool is really there
and it's really kind of working.
It's very protective
and I think what can,
Tesla has been saying it
absolutely correct that I
would really love to see
India produce its own IAMs
and it has the capacity to do that.
And I think that I really,
where we have to make sure we're
challenged by different expertise
and that the experts in India
have their own expertise
that they can really can bring to it
and we have to be accepting
of their expertise,
just like the expertise
of communities in Brazil.
They have their own expertise
and we have to be open to that
inclusive to that,
just to myself just have to be inclusive
to the economist out there
that perhaps are be excluded
by this conversation.
- Including excluding
I think that there's,
I mean there's clearly a
very large agenda to be,
to both be articulated in
terms of what are the social,
what are the questions
that require an understanding
of both the human
and social dynamics in order to make well.
And there's an enormous set
of tasks on reducing the frictions.
I think the good news is that
there are a number of people
who are already involved in that,
who are doing it because they see the need
and we are in some ways
fumbling toward doing
that better and better.
I wanna leave the last 15 minutes
for questions from the audience
because I'm seeing a bunch of
hands and twisting, Costas.
- Thank you.
Climate models and we have
less rich economic models
and I mean it is a cost
question of cost benefit.
Lemme try, there's a cost of cost benefit,
where do you start, right?
Tony has like already the rich model,
but what is the elements
that you want to put first?
A few elements like heterogeneous agents
or you know, like what,
more capital choices or
something more many sectors.
Where do you start?
- I think at least in
the economics literature
and the general equilibrium
macro literature,
I think what's been missing,
although it is a growing
field now is looking
at heterogeneity of
impacts of climate change
and climate policy
around the world getting
at questions of inequality.
I think that's just been missing.
But I think we're starting to build models
that economists all
certainly are buying into
to address those questions.
And I think one thing that's
missing big time still
is that's why I'm working on it.
So I'm tooting my own horn here,
but I think we pretty much
just are putting an average
temperature, no weather
and just viewing that
as the main variable,
which it probably is, but I think
we should be looking at
extreme weather events as well.
Putting in weather as well
as climate into the models and recognizing
that weather can impact locally.
Maybe not, it doesn't,
we don't get a hurricane
across the whole US,
we get a hurricane locally.
So we need to model those
somewhat more local impacts
and then study how we
can share those risks
across governments or countries.
So I think it's quite important
to bring in inequality
that there's heterogeneity impacts.
I think that's pretty
well established by now,
but when I first did my
first version of the model,
like this is crazy how it is
coming out so heterogeneous
and I think weather is
just super important.
There's some work I think
Rossi Hanberg and Bilal,
the paper that Sam
mentioned earlier is doing
some of that, but we need
to do much more of that.
I would think.
And that requires bringing in the richness
of earth system models or maybe using
a very good emulator
that will let us look at
regional weather impacts.
- So I'm not sure if what I'm
about to say is a question
or a comment, but I felt
like this was so pessimistic
compared to well having,
spent nearly two years in the
White House science office
and looking at how science
was coming into policy.
I came away from that
experience being completely odd,
at least how much science
we were trying to gobble up
and organize and repackage
and how important it was.
And what I took away was
that there's a missing link
in the feedback scientists
get when that happens.
And I think this is part of the challenge
is it's, I think we as a
scientific community have
to also think about like what feedbacks
are we actually expecting?
Because it seemed to me when
I was at the White House,
like the most important work
was like, you don't cite it,
you let the secretary take credit for it
or you say,
you let somebody else take
it's plagiarism was actually,
I don't wanna accuse the
White House of plagiarism,
but like just poaching stuff was like,
that's the really important stuff.
When you start studying
it's less important.
And so I'm wondering
just what do we expect
as a scientific community in a world where
we're super unique as researchers.
Like people read our
papers, they cite them,
this is how we evaluate stuff.
We look at like exactly we count.
But even if you go to
like a corporate world,
nobody knows exactly
anybody's individual impact.
And so how we're operating
with a world in policy
that like individual
impacts aren't tracked
and so what are our
expectations for being able
to think about how our sciences
is responsive to policy
and how we understand that
and how we get those signals back.
- Does anyone have any thoughts on that?
I think it's an excellent question.
- And I would say that I've had
exactly the same experience,
that yeah, I do see lots
of examples in my career
where it's really worked very well
and that we should take
optimism from that though.
But I've also through the IPCC,
I work in other countries a lot
and I think in a lot
of countries they don't have
the same capacity there.
And so perhaps that is really
something that kind of tell
and kind of Regina could comment on.
You said you came from a
particularly bad kind part
of in Brazil where they
completely ignored you.
- Well lemme just get my thoughts here.
The thing is that I think
we have a lot of information
for mitigation purpose.
What makes me like, I think
the frustrated is that
we know what we have to do,
but politically in the high levels,
we are not having the engagement.
This is very upsetting
and I'm not optimistic when
I look into the mitigation
aspect and I know that we
already have enough information
that we needed to get
to net zero, etcetera.
But what give me hope is when I look
to the bottom up approach that I say,
which is more this
grassroots process of empower
the local community to make
sense, then we can build trust.
We can use that conversation
in a local level,
but it's not like for scientists,
that's sometimes it's not
so glorious as the high level.
Scientists wanna get up there,
they wanna just talk to,
and make a difference with politics
and in a high level.
And it's not like a,
but I see hope in the grassroots
science developing this.
So I dunno if I passed this pessimistic,
but when I think about the
bottom up approach in terms
of climate science with communities,
then I think we will change.
'Cause in this conversation
it can change even
how they vote, you know?
And that's what think gonna
make much more impact than try
to talk to the politics
and change in their mind.
- Tejal, did you have anything
to add on this point?
- Can't hear you.
- Apologies, can you hear me now?
- Now we can hear you.
- Yeah. Alright.
No, so just briefly,
I mean I'm sorry if I,
I contributed to the
pessimism of the message,
but I don't think it's a,
there is a problem.
In fact in a lot of developing
countries you have far more
ready uptake of the signs.
You have far less climate
denial in developing countries
irrespective of capacities,
perhaps scientific in-house
scientific capacities.
There has been much more adoption.
Clearly of climate policies across regions
in the developing world.
In India for example, you have,
agricultural departments and
newer crop models coming up
and people working at regional
and national level models as well
as actually working on the
field trying to experiment.
And this is a change remarkably
in a very short span of time.
Given that we work in academic time spans,
we don't think,
there's that much of an
impact and I agree that some
of this cannot be measured
in terms of publications
and citations and it shouldn't be.
But unfortunately we are also
slaves to our professions
and that's what gets
us tenure, for example.
So you need to publish and that's
how we end up thinking
about measuring our impact.
But it is true that there is,
there has been significant
shifts in the way in which people
are thinking about the
environment and climate,
even in developing countries
where you may not have as much
of a footprint of the science
as you do in developed countries.
But I think the question for example
of what constitutes the a correct
interpretation of science,
where this entire focus on net zero
in the developed countries
is only a partial adoption
of what the real science is.
Nobody's talking about carbon budgets.
In fact, the UK that spoke
about carbon budgets,
which is in fact the more
complete measure of warming,
it spoke about it in its earlier plans,
but has now moved away from
it in pursuit of net zero.
So you have, sometimes
even science feeding into,
it's not just science
providing evidence for policy,
but policy makers telling scientists
what they would like to hear,
what it is convenient for them to hear.
And I think this goes back to
a little bit of the question
that Jessica had about
the pull and push, right?
Is it always the case
that you have scientists
who are studying this
with all the uncertainties
involved telling policy makers
this is what we have and
this is what is happening.
Or do you also have now situation
where policy makers know
to a certain extent
what the challenges are
and what the issues are,
but they also ha know that
there's inertia in the system
and they're giving a
message to the scientists
that this much is convenient to us.
So don't amplify the
scientific message beyond that.
And I am a little fearful that this is
what is happening that you have,
we are past the era
where scientists were
pushing for certain policies
and you have,
you have now scientists being dictated to,
in terms of what kind
of science to produce and that's becoming
a bit of a problem.
So we perhaps need to reverse the trend
and push once again.
Go back to an era where we needed
to push maybe reality of approaches,
welcome heterogeneity in
terms of different approaches
and perspectives in terms
of how we do the modeling.
Thank you.
- So this has been a.
- Go ahead.
- I just wanted to add a,
maybe a more optimistic point,
but first I'll start with a nor a story
about Nordhaus', pessimistic,
very first version,
if you read his biography
that he put up for the Nobel Prize.
The very first version
of his very first climate
model was rejected
by all the economics journals.
He had to publish it in science.
But I think that's, this is
where I'll switch to optimistic.
I think within economics there's been,
I think an explosion of research
on climate since I started
working on this 10 years ago or something.
I think the pull factor,
there might be partly just climate change.
We can see it really happening.
It's like it seems really important
and maybe it didn't seem before.
Also, I think environmental
economics is viewed
as more methodologically interesting
than maybe it was before,
maybe it was unfair to
environmental economics,
but be seeing like you can
use all these modern tools
from other IO or from
Micro and bring them in,
bring 'em here.
But where I'm a little more
pessimistic is whether you can
convince economists to get
actively involved in the policy world.
'Cause we don't reward that for tenure.
And then working across the,
so economists are maybe happy
with their models, but
then I find skepticism from
sociologists or maybe climate
scientists about what I'm doing.
So to really have influence
in the broader world.
But you kind of want to confront,
you need to talk to other
types of social scientists
and I think that's not rewarded so much.
- So I'm getting the flag
that we're at the end of our time.
But I just wanted to flag that
that this particular
interaction is actually
an environmental social feedback loop
that we don't know that much about
and sort of proves the point of the panel.
How do we tell better structured,
informative stories about
how to amplify exactly
this loop between seeing the change,
being more excited about it,
having more conversations.
This isn't humans and
climate models and climate
and human models, but this
is the kind of conversation
that we need to figure
out how to represent,
understand, and amplify.
So we'll leave it on that optimistic note
and that to-do list for all of us
and head into the reception and dinner.
The panel will be around.
And Tejal, thank you
so much for joining us.
I hope you do get some sleep
and we'll be following up.
If you have questions for
Tejal, I think just let me know
and we can convey them to Tejal
and hopefully build
something from this panel
to amplify the interaction.
Thank you.
(people clapping)
(soft music)